hello everyone and welcome back to the
final edition of the grand prix of the
2021 corporate chess league fall season
as always my name is caleb denby and i
will be your host tonight it's been a
wonderful season so far we've had a lot
of exciting games and quite a few
turnarounds namely edward jones making a
big comeback had some unfortunate
forfeits in the first week of the
corporate chess league but now they are
back in action and why don't we actually
see where they and all the other teams
stand uh after i believe four weeks of
play five weeks of play something like
that
this is week five and we have enterprise
standing at the top of the leaderboard
going into this final week here uh
trailing them is worldwide technology
and edward jones trying to complete
their comeback here tonight uh following
them is ascension and those four teams
have mathematically qualified themselves
for the final four so unfortunately for
bayer and darty they made a great
showing here uh in the 21 2021 season
but this is the last we will see of them
tonight as they are unable to qualify
for the final four championships
happening next week
that being said there's a lot to play
for here tonight namely bragging rights
these guys they're not going to be happy
just qualifying for the final four they
want to go home they want to say i won
the grand prix it was never in doubt i
am getting the best seating in the final
four which by the way is not entirely
irrelevant should a match go down to
armageddon in the final four the higher
seed is going to be able to pick their
color so look out for that higher seed
with a slight edge in the event of a
time
that being said if you think your
corporation has what it takes to win the
2021 corporate chess league
you yourself can get involved
do that by reaching out to us at the
email on your screen development at
stlouischestclub.org we would be
absolutely thrilled to have more
corporations and more teams joining the
league
outside of that it's going to be a very
exciting night tonight let's take a
quick look at the pairings we've got
enterprise uh squaring off against
worldwide technology in the first round
of the night and edward jones is up
against ascension and that leaves bayer
and dardy fighting it out
as well and to start with i believe i
want to follow this enterprise worldwide
technology match they're the top two
scoring teams so far this year and so
it's going to be interesting to see what
they can
do
so let's see if i can pull up
the games it looks like they are getting
underway already
let's see kamikaze knight board one for
enterprise has been doing uh absolutely
fantastic in the corporate chess league
so far
um i don't know if he's won every single
game he's played but it's been close
it's been that bad it's been that bad
for his opponents so let's see if he can
get it done here against mjc 3801 for
worldwide technology
and it looks like we have a kero con on
our hands we have a kero khan
so in the carrow
black develops the light squared bishop
outside of the pawn chain to make this
piece a little bit more active than
normal
and then in exchange for that white is
building this big center right it has
all this central space and is going to
try to roll these pawns forward to give
black some problems in the meanwhile
black is hoping to eventually play this
move c5 now what's the point of c5 black
wants to challenge the big center crack
open some files on the queen side and
find counter play over here
that being said i don't think black has
done a very good job of organizing the
pieces here as you can see
he has not yet played this move c5 and
on move 11 now you kind of needed this
move to come just a little bit more
quickly
for counter play
because this pawn is not yet on c5 you
see kamikaze knight is able to expand
out now with this move b4 just totally
clamping down on this square it's going
to be hard for black to find that
counter play that he needs to stay in
the game
if i'm white i'm feeling very very
comfortable here play something like
knight b3 as kamikaze knight does after
it takes takes
the a file is not going to be too much
white can also play a5 and just its dark
square domination all over the
chessboard for kamikaze night not how i
like to see my beloved caro khan going
okay but we'll let uh mjc try and worm
his way out of this one let's take a
look at the game between moneyballin and
dv dutch moneyballin of course playing
for enterprise dv dutch playing for
worldwide technology and neither player
has an accurate chess.com rating no way
is dv dutch actually 1100 strength no
way is moneyballing actually 1400
strength uh if i had to guess i think
both of these players around 15 1600
over the board
so what's going on in this game we have
a benko declined it looks like very
interesting so the benko gambit of
course black quickly fights for these
dark squares in the center allows white
to take extra space but then very
immediately challenges this central pawn
the c pawn defends the pawn on d5 black
offers up a an entire free pawn on the
queen side uh just to weaken this d5
pawn a little bit of course if the c
pawn were to capture the d-pawn is going
to be a little bit weaker and black is
going to play for some open files on the
queen side white actually declines this
though allowing black to capture a pawn
for free on c4
but white is saying he's going to get
this pawn back in good time we get e4 d6
white could actually capture this pawn
already but instead goes for e5 opening
things up very very early on
d takes knight takes bishop g7 queen a4
is check and now bishop d7 and that's
where we stand at the moment
interesting stuff by
moneyballing potentially this line
might be working out for them
but in general it's not such a good idea
to try and open things up so so quickly
when you're actually the one behind on
development here you see black is able
to castle in just one move it's going to
take white a couple moves to castle and
because of that all these open lines
might actually come back to uh to hurt
moneyball in here so we'll see what
happens we have bishop d7 now hitting
this queen on c4
on a4 so queen takes c4 is played now if
i'm black i just want to castle my king
and then i'm going to let the position
speak for itself you know i've got this
bishop here on g7 thanks to my opponent
this line is now wide open raking down
the board
and black is going to be playing with
some very very active pieces
in the meantime though uh you know the c
pawn is a c pawn
um white not quite that greedy though
does play bishop b2 does prepare to
castle his own king i might have just
preferred to see him do all of this
before playing this e5 break before
ripping things open
okay queen b6 now is going to defend the
pawn on c5
if i'm white i'm probably just thinking
about castling
uh and at the end of the day you know i
think white might have gotten away with
it um again maybe it was all working
from the start it just looked a little
bit risky
but now you know white's king is is also
going to be castled black still has one
or two tempe to make something happen
but if nothing happens here
we've got some very active pieces for
white this deep d5 pawn hampers black's
development this queen on c4
applies a nice little bit of pressure to
this pawn on c5
and white might be doing well might
might be doing well
and yes of course hello to everyone
watching in the youtube chats
and oh my goodness what is this
what is this dv touch what is this
knight a6 knight a6 not so good loses a
piece to moneyballin so looking good for
enterprise now
and you know it's easy to write knight
a6 off as a blunder but i do want to
give credit to moneyball in here
you know a blunder like 96 is not going
to happen if your opponent has easy
natural developing moves so uh inducing
blunders by making it difficult to
develop is
something worth mentioning so dv dutch
just going to be down a piece now so
looking good for enterprise on this
sport let's take a look at board 3 which
is going to be
kendalum i believe if i can find
that game maybe i can't find that game
kenjalum versus sweetman
and oh my oh my sweet man is not online
perhaps that game never got started
rather unfortunate so
that is not looking very good for
worldwide technology although i do see
some action on our pairing spreadsheet
perhaps they are getting connected now
and that game is going to get underway
in the meantime though that brings us to
board 4 which is going to be 21
gigawatts for enterprise up against
derek for free
for worldwide technology
and what a position we have here so
looks like black black's f-pawn went
missing how did black's f-pawn go
missing ah he put it on f5 so
f5 of course a very aggressive move
but it is going to lead to some very
long-term weaknesses on this diagonal
so because of this f5 move we're gonna
see that's uh what happened in the game
uh oh just just checkmate immediately it
turns out those long-term weaknesses
became very uh short-term weaknesses
because the game just just ended
but again credit where credits do these
are not just super simple blunders they
are induced by the empire by the
opponents when you're in a tough
position it's really easy to slip up and
make a bad blunder when you have a great
position it's not going to happen quite
as often so five making a few too many
light squared weaknesses i think and
that's what led to uh derrick for free
taking home that win
and with that worldwide technology is
off to a lead in the match winning one
to nothing
let's check back in on board one see how
this game is developed we had a rather
awkward looking karo khan when we last
left it we left it around this time when
white played this move knight b3 i
highlighted all the dark squares and
said white was doing well then we get
knight f5 a trait of these pieces and f4
by white interesting oh and bishop g4 i
actually hate this move uh oh and bishop
e4
oh my gosh
okay neither player i think is
um
making much sense here
okay so one of the how do i explain this
so the the bishop uh in the caro khan is
a very very important piece it's sort of
the heart of the position has to deal
with this bishop so on the one hand it's
an active piece raking down this
diagonal outside the pawn chain on the
other hand when you lock your bishop
outside the pawn chain it occasionally
can run into some trouble can run short
on squares and it's a little bit more
vulnerable to attack so often times in
the carol con you'll see white play a
move like g4 and start expanding on the
king's side because he's able to gain a
lot of time against this bishop outside
the pawn chain so something like g4 hits
the bishop forces it to a square like e4
can even drop the knight back to d2
try and induce the bishop back and then
hit black with f5 now that's like the
best case scenario
but that is sort of the main idea in the
position and then after we've gained a
ton of tempe against this bishop we've
kicked it all over the board maybe then
we'll consider trading off these bishops
but but only after we get all those
advantages
um and so
after bishop g4 as black i would be very
tempted to just accept this trade of
these bishops uh get those bishops off
the board so that white doesn't gain all
this time but instead neither player
does what i want them to do
which is interesting okay f6 f5 is how
this game wins and then b5 does allow c5
by black i would have liked to see
white hold off on this b5 move for as
long as possible because now that after
c5 is played we are going to see just a
few things open up here
and h6 can't be can't be right so
it looks like the the complications are
still gonna be favoring white in in this
position
um
if i'm not miscounting this is gonna be
an extra piece
uh so what went wrong here what went
wrong after c5 kamikaze knight struck
while the iron was hot with this move c4
i think that's definitely the way to go
and then unfortunately here uh i think
uh takes on c4 was just a little bit too
careless i do believe black needed to be
the one to strike first with c takes d4
instead
because after this line we see that
after rook c1 it's just a little bit
awkward here for black to try and
try and resolve this tension and white
was able to make a threat and resolve
the tension by winning a piece okay so
looking good for kamikaze night now but
uh missing some nuances
in uh
in the caro con there
still no sign of sweet man by the way so
worldwide technology might be
might be getting a double forfeit here
in just a moment
oh and what is this i'm looking at the
uh pairing score sheet and it looks like
ascension is off to an early lead with
davinators defeating board one for
edward jones vishal of bardwash so
that's an interesting start over there
i am going to leave this kamikaze knight
game now uh we can check back in briefly
on moneyballin yup moneyball and still
up a piece still looks good
and so it looks like uh enterprise is
definitely off to a very good start here
despite dropping that board for game
against derek for free okay why don't we
move on over to this uh edward jones
ascension matchup let's take a look here
see what happened in this game between
vishal and davenators
so vishal wait what is this
he got checkmated oh my goodness vishal
here just up a full rook
was getting checked all over the board
oh my goodness okay what a game so we
had knight takes f2 winning in exchange
and then after queen f7 queen f6
uh we see that white is able to flush
out this black king one way or another
with knight f7
and then queen h6 sacrifices the knight
as well
but then at the end of the day
uh okay i think white missed
uh white missed an opportunity here with
with rookie six instead he goes queen e6
and we shuffle back and forth for a
while eventually rook g3 hits
vishal does not choose to sacrifice back
tries to keep the extra material
um and then okay uh chess.com is taking
the game out of my hands but um it looks
like uh the the king got ran over to the
queen side and and was eventually
checkmated over there what a crazy crazy
game for davenators to to go off to an
early lead
uh really wild stuff let's see how
they're doing in the rematch of course
everybody plays two games per per round
here one with black and one with white
okay so let's see what's going on
vishal hoping to recover
chooses a slightly
more conservative opening puts a pawn in
the center develops the king's side
keeps his king safe as opposed to last
game and then we're going to end up with
c3 here which is a rather interesting
idea
white is trying to support the d4 pawn
in order to liberate his e pawn to jump
right out to e4
more of a king's indian attack style of
play
if i can catch back up okay we get a3
and then actually c4 so vishal perhaps
realizes that black has good control
over the e4 square shifts his game plan
uh to the c4 break instead
and then we get takes knight e5 and yeah
rook b8 doesn't feel like the correct
way to uh to answer this now all of a
sudden
uh vishal is taking over the board yeah
winning a piece with this tactic this is
a tactic that shows up at pretty much
all levels of chess but when you develop
all your pieces to the most natural
squares
it turns out that e4 attacks a piece and
then e5 forks two other pieces one of
the most common tactics in chess
but that tactic good enough here to win
a piece and now vishal already is is
just
launching down the board on the king's
side bishop d3 is a clever way to save
the bishop
uh but that's all it does if white uh
were to take
black can take back
um but white is still gonna have this
extra bishop so looking good for vishal
making his big comeback
let's see what's going on on board two
between fishers of men and
uh s gilmore we've got fishers of men
with the black pieces here
and another sort of locked up position
going on
so if i can count the pawns if i'm not
mistaken both sides have all eight of
their pawns remaining that doesn't
doesn't happen too often although white
structure is looking a little bit more
fractured than blacks
so what's going on in this position
we have the c and the d-pawns in tension
it's always a good idea to look at
that area where the pawns are attacking
each other that's where a lot of the
action is going to take place that's
where things are going to open up and
that's usually what the position centers
around
so what's going on here well at any
moment black could take opening up this
bishop on the long diagonal but black is
probably hesitant to do that because
that's going to activate white's bishop
as well along this diagonal opposing the
king and attacking this weak pawn on e6
conversely white would be able to take
on d5 to open up this bishop but that's
going to allow black's bishop to control
both of these very important diagonals
and so that's why we see neither player
willing to break the tension just yet
instead black's idea is to jump out to
queen a4 try and poke at some of these
pawns on the queen side
and find an advantage that way
now if you play the simple move king b1
perhaps black is very seriously
considering taking this pawn on c4 now
that the queen is here for backup
white's bishop not going to be able to
activate and black's bishop is going to
be the one that is springing to life so
we do see king b1 and i'm very
interested to see if black will decide
to take on c4
the other reason that white or that
black might be hesitant is it does open
up this file for the rook as well and
you could argue that that is going to be
a a pretty big benefit for white here
so that's the decision fishers of men is
faced with does he open it up or does he
keep it closed keeps it closed plays
simple move rook d8 rook d7 something
like that even bishop a6 has some ideas
although it doesn't work immediately
so plenty of options here for fishers
and men and i want to see what he is
going to choose
hello to anthony in the chat room as
well thank you thank you for joining
understandably fisher's men is taking
just a minute here and he does he opens
it up so the fireworks are are coming
now will we see rook d6 planting this
rook
in black's face again attacking this
major major weakness in the white camp
and then after d6 will we see bishop e4
check queen c2 these kinds of ideas it's
going to be
going to be some action here
now that things have finally opened up
yeah rook d6 comes on the board i'm
expecting bishop e4 check just to
activate that bishop
bishop d5 looks sort of artificially
very very strong but i think bishop f3
is going to be enough if you try some
kind of c3 tactic i'm just going to take
your bishop
oh okay so this is what's um
this is what fishers of men goes for and
this does make some very frightening
looking threats i do think that bishop
f3 is the way to go here and after
bishop f3
i think white is
potentially even getting the better side
of things
potentially getting the better side of
things
bishop f3 i think black actually is
going to have to just give up on all
these tactics play a move like rook d7
and
try and make sure he isn't going to be
any worse
just to show you what i'm thinking so
bishop f3 or d7 maybe he can take on d5
and take back with the pawn and then my
rook on d7 sort of defends my pawn on d5
which is much needed okay instead we see
bishop to d1 i don't think this spoils
anything for white why black can move
the queen out of the way b4 a5 would
make a lot of sense
and then white can still come out with
this move bishop f3
white can still play this move
in the meantime we are getting some more
results in uh and yeah edward jones as
they often do is uh surging
against ascension so vishal doing well
in his game after dropping game one to
davenators of ascension and now justini
linguini and alex curford getting it
done on boards three and four for edward
jones
uh so edward jones now does officially
take the lead uh by the way kamikaze
knight and money bullen both got the job
done against their opponents as expected
they were both up a piece
so no surprise that they ended up taking
home the full points
uh in the meantime sweet man has arrived
on the scene sweet man is here uh
finally his game against pendulum is
underway so no forfeits for worldwide
technology thankfully sweet man shows up
just in the nick of time and has a great
position nonetheless
so if sweet man is able to win this game
we will have a tied match in the
enterprise versus worldwide technology
dual
i don't want to lose sight of this
though because i think this is very very
interesting so wow g4 is white's choice
i was worried that white might get
ambitious like this because now the c3
idea just feels like it's it's creating
so many weaknesses in
in the white camp you can play b take c3
trying to defend laterally but then
stuff like queen d3 check in oh queen b7
what is queen b7 i thought bishop d5 was
your attacking chance to break in with
c3 i thought fishers of men was was
coming after the guy but instead he goes
more passive with queen to b7
i don't like this idea i don't like this
idea at all and in the meantime i think
we have some background music starting
so there is a concert going on above us
so you may hear some some interesting
things here tonight
during the corporate chess league
um okay so with that in mind i think
gilmore is now on the upper side of
things with the strong past e5 pawn uh
and black's piece is heading in the
wrong direction
so that's where i'll leave this one
let's check back in on pendulum versus
sweet man
and i look away for two seconds and
some pieces drop off the board
oh no how long has wiping down a rook
okay i didn't even realize okay white
has been down a rook for a while so
maybe this game's not so interesting
because an extra rook is going to be
good enough for sweet man
so with that uh i can say that worldwide
technology is very very likely tying
this match against enterprise is this a
sign of things to come i'm not so sure
what i do know is that if anybody is
going to defeat enterprise they need to
do something about kamikaze knight this
guy just wins every game he plays in the
corporate chess league it's honestly
it's it's embarrassing i'm embarrassed
other corporate chess league teams you
can't just like kamikaze knight roll
over you guys like this somebody's got
to take him out somebody has got to take
him out
so we get queen g1 king c2
and this position is still it's got some
life in it still i know black is up the
exchange
but this knight on f6 is a very very
scary piece
and there's even weird moves like knight
to h7 that i'm considering here because
the black queen is just a little bit
offside
a little bit far away from the black
king if we can cut off this king's
escape route through f8 i might be able
to get some interesting at least
perpetuals against this black king the
rook is not going to be enough to stop
the queen and the knight
so we see queen b7 first i was worried
that white might go for this because now
i do believe
uh that
black's king is going to be escaping
through f8 i wanted to stop that if at
all possible
definitely it's not over yet though
knight h7 is still in this position but
now i think that the best white is
hoping for is gonna be some kind of a
draw
uh and that's if he's fortunate enough
to not get checkmated in in the interim
uh for example if i go knight h7
king to g8
yeah i'm honestly not even seeing the
draw if you go knight f6 king h king h8
and i am i am escaping
i am escaping
okay queen c7 instead oh and so this is
the perpetual that's uh
that white is going for here not against
the king but actually against the rook
very interesting idea i think we're
going to see these pieces shuffle back
and forth between a8 and d8 and c7 and
b7
and that might be enough to to draw the
game
in the meantime kamikaze knight at any
moment can insert a flurry of checks
white should be careful not to step to
the third rank otherwise the pawns start
falling with check
um but
maybe just a draw maybe just a draw i'm
not so sure
we'll stick with this one for a while
because this is going to be a big game
if kamikaze knight is able to uh or if
mjc is able to stop kamikaze knight here
hold him at least to a draw that gives
his team good chances to uh to come back
and win this match by the way on board
for 21 gigabots and derrick for free
drew their second game so no change in
the standings there
and we did see fishers of men and s
gilmore actually draw
that game that i was looking at that
looked
quite interesting
actually no i think that was the first
game they played yeah they are still
well underway and just briefly looking
at it it looks like
uh white is
checkmated hold on we gotta check this
out what happened here
i was gonna say i thought white is is
doing well and then we have white
sacrificing a rook for for no apparent
reason
why why did we sacrifice a full rook for
no reason i don't understand
i don't understand it's checkmates it's
just gonna be checkmate now just queen
d5
this is very hard to stop and your
attack against the black king is going
nowhere
um so just to give you uh some words of
wisdom here gary kasparov has kind of a
rule
actually there's a lot of different
rules that people have made up for for
when you can sacrifice
but if you kind of cut the board into
fourths and you have a massive advantage
of material on one side of the board
that's when you can attack but here all
of black's pieces are very ready to come
back to the king's side to help defend
and so this sacrifice just isn't going
to make any sense just isn't going to
make any sense so
uh unforced air by s gilmore here and i
think that's going to cost him the game
uh barring you know any any miracles
with with the pawn promoting here
and even if the pawn promotes here 25
seconds on the clock is it's gonna be
tough
okay so we'll leave that in the hands of
uh
fishers of men for edward jones and
we'll come back to this this game where
yeah i really don't like this decision
by by whites i i think that white is
definitely fighting for a draw here and
not anymore so i think queen b7 was the
way to go you just want to shuffle back
and forth get that repetition make
kamikaze knight be the one to deviate if
he does want to avoid the draw
because here i mean you're just down in
exchange and you're you're not
checkmating this this king
okay running the king all the way to the
edge also probably not going to be
advised um now the queen is going to
come in
and i think you're you're very close
check made it you're very very close to
checkmate and i'm not even sure you know
how you continue here like at any moment
just rook c8 and the the two major
pieces will will checkmate the white
king
at any moment rook c8 could come
okay we get queen d3 check first
now queen c2 i'm anticipating
maybe just rook c8
i think both are fine
and your checks are going nowhere you
have one check knight h5 i play king h8
i'm entirely safe and you are
busted
just busted
so kamikaze knight gets it done again
another 2-0 uh win for kamikaze knight
as always performing strongly in this
corporate chess league
um that leaves the the fate of the match
in the hands of moneyballin
and dv dutch along with kendalum and and
sweetman
so let's check in on those games we've
got db dutch versus moneyballin i saw dv
dutch making an unfortunate blunder
in the benko gambit
last round but here we see yeah we see
dv dutch again actually down a piece so
not going great again
this bishop is actually going to make a
big difference as well this bishop's
coming into f4
and delivering checkmate on on age two
so what can white do about it how do you
stop checkmate maybe you have to play
this move queen f3 just trade off the
queens
uh instead uh dv dutch understandably
does not want to trade off the queens
but now just just bishop f4
and that's going to be the end of the
game
so with that is that enough to just
straight win the match
that is going to
bump up enterprise's score likely to
four and a half points
which is enough to win the match so
assuming no surprises in the kamikaze
knight mjc game and no surprises here
enterprise will be defeating worldwide
technology and securing those extra
grand prix points
hello to those of you in the chat johnny
spin mathis
rival
thank you for joining all the way from
france hello hello
okay so with that i am going to leave
this enterprise worldwide technology
matchup because i think things have just
fully been decided there
um the only match where there is still
some controversy is going to be bayer
versus doherty
where they are coming down to the wire
it's all coming down to this final game
between i love legos 2 and cross to pj
if
i love legos 2 is able to win he will
secure a tie for dougherty if bayer
wants to win then they need a half point
out of cross to pj
and okay i just looked at the board and
black has more rooks so it does look
like bayer is going to get it done here
with uh with their match against tardy
um yeah c6 black is super solid no way
in for the white pieces white does have
some scary looking pawns but all of the
pieces are working together good
coordination for black and so he should
be able to hold everything together
queen e3 this is a nice move a little
defense of h3 and a sneaky little threat
of queen takes a7
so not out of the question that i love
legos 2 could make a comeback in this
game but with only 19 seconds
it's just not going to happen it's just
not going to happen queen a7
you can get away with queen takes h3
here because you have so many major
pieces around your king you're going to
uh to be fine
by the way queen b8 seems like it's
picking up a rook but after i go king h7
takes rook takes g4 you actually have to
give up your queen right back
and your victory is is going to be
short-lived in the meantime edward jones
has secured match victory against
ascension vishal did get it done in his
second game after losing uh horribly to
davinators in some sort of checkmating
uh king hunt in game one
and that just leaves alex kirford's game
left underway and yeah actually that
line that i was mentioning does appear
on the board uh black now up a queen for
rook and actually is just able to to
take everything uh or fork the king and
work immediately
okay i love legos two flags and with
that bayer secures their match victory
as well that leaves just this
one no two games underway we have alex
kirford here with the white pieces and
uh quite a few white pieces against oak
ave who does not have many black pieces
left
uh and alex perhaps being a little bit
mean here um not finding checkmate with
his extra pieces and instead is pushing
yet another pawn down on the board
okay we have check and mate
okay now it's a little bit harder
alex 30 seconds on the clock stalemate's
not out of the question here not out of
the question okay checking mage is there
again
okay now check and mate
or mate
yeah mate is good alex wins that game
and that brings us to the final game of
round one of the corporate chess league
which is going to be between kendall and
sweet man so unfortunately for sweet man
his team has mathematically lost this
round already uh but if he is able to
win it will
only be lost by a very respectable half
point i think if they had scored just a
half point more on board four they would
have tied the match assuming a win out
of sweet man that being said assuming a
win out of suiteman is not going to be a
guarantee here black
does seem to have a very good position
and impressive rebounds by a lot of the
players in the event here tonight we saw
vishal losing an unfortunate game and
bouncing back to win now kendall with a
very good night a very good looking
position
after his loss in the first game as well
that being said it's not all roses for
black here you are missing a very
critical c pawn that would help defend
your entire structure so there are some
loose spots
for black to look out for this pawn on
d5 just a little bit too loose for my
liking and if this something were to
happen to this pawn all of a sudden your
knight on e4 loses its legs its legs get
kicked out from underneath it and it
would come tumbling down would have to
leave its outpost on the e4 square
so definitely a lot to keep track of
here for black but i do think it's
manageable and if black does manage
everything it's just got a better
position more active pieces more space
and better coordination you see this
queen
floating out here on h3 this bishop not
doing much as well and this knight's
forward hops taken away by this pawn on
f6
so good position here for pendulum
and we'll stick with it to to see if he
can manage to convert it
queen to g2 by the way i think queen to
g4 might be getting your queen trapped
some f5 business although the story is a
little bit more complicated with knight
g5 check so better just to go back to g2
regroup and stay solid
best to just stay solid and yes hello to
alex in the chats who just finished up
his game against oak ave
securing match victory for edward jones
and alex correct me if i'm wrong but if
i know these corporate chesley teams you
guys you're not happy with just
qualifying for the final four you're
looking to take enterprises top spot
here tonight
and
so that is what we are keeping an eye on
let me just
take a brief gander at the total grand
prix standings after this round i do
believe edward jones will leapfrog
worldwide technology to come into second
place and that puts them definitely
within striking distance of taking
enterprises uh top spot in round number
two of tonight that'll be a match that
we definitely want to follow
so yeah it looks like
enterprise will have something like a
25 point lead over edward jones so it
would have to be a blowout for edward
jones to leapfrog them but it is
definitely doable they just need to win
a lot of games
not enough to win the match in a close
battle you gotta gotta crush him gotta
crush him to get it done
okay in the meantime we see black
doubling up on the h file now and you
can really see the power of this knight
on e4 it's keeping
you know something like 20 points worth
of material at bay for uh for for white
almost single-handedly like this knight
just it's
stuck in the way of all of the open
lines for whites nothing to be done
about it
a3 and i said nothing to be done about
it but realistically you probably had to
play knight d2 there just trying to get
rid of this piece now the reason why 92
wasn't played
white was probably concerned about this
rook h2 idea and rightfully so
so if you can't play knight d2 then you
can't get rid of this knight in e4 if
you can't get rid of this knight on e4
none of your pieces can play so that's
the dilemma that kendalum has backed
sweet man into here
it's going to take some creativity to uh
to untangle this one honestly if i'm
white here i'm very very seriously
tempted to just get rid of this stupid
knight on on e4 like how can you play
chess stuck behind this knight
how can you play chess like this
and the answer is you can't which is why
sweet man hasn't made a move there's
just no way to move your pieces here
unless you take this knight off the
board you definitely don't want to make
this sacrifice as white but it's it's a
sacrifice of necessity and yeah sweet
man does eventually muster up the
courage to uh to take that piece off the
board
simply had to be done it simply had to
be done
okay now the character of the game is
going to change a little bit you see
that this wide open diagonal is where
the black king resides
and so white now looking to spring to
life activate all the pieces use this
open e file and counter attack uh in the
meanwhile if black is able to
consolidate secure everything uh he will
just be up the exchange at the end of
the day
okay queen to d7 this move feels a
little bit funny our queen i think
actually had more options on the c7
square than d7 maybe kendall is eyeing
up this f5 square but i would rather
plant this queen somewhere like c4 you
know look at this square look at this
square look at these invading
opportunities all in the meanwhile
keeping my backwards
moves to help defend my king
also not a huge fan of this rook sitting
here on h3 maybe this is the reason
behind queen to d7 just giving this guy
a little bit more support
okay king f1 okay i'm not a fan of this
move either this one just feels very
very strange your king is safer on g1
than f1 queen b5 is check can take a
pawn can invade
sort of gives black a second chance here
to improve the queen
queen b5 it is
rookie 2 is going to run into rookie 8.
i don't care about this rook i get this
rook and i get my pieces in the game
we'll see if pendulum can find it
g4 instead okay this is an attempt at an
improvement over my line he wants to
play rookie 8 but he doesn't want to hit
his rook so he defends his rook first
and now i fully expect rookie 8 to
appear on the board
fully expect rookie 8
what else
okay so rookie 8 is here
white now i think has to play some some
move like bishop to g1
and yeah
again necessity is the mother of
invention
or something like that bishop g1
you don't want to play it
it might not occur to you but when you
have to play it you have to play it
i'm looking at some very funny stuff now
i'm looking at bishop g3 pawn g3 rook g3
if queen takes there is checkmate and i
think that would be uh a very beautiful
way to finish this game but i'm not
going to put all that on pendulum bishop
takes g3 not the easiest move to find
uh in the meantime
trading pieces is not the worst idea
either okay g5 instead this one's not my
favorite but uh pendulum is just trying
to to keep the tension here he says your
rook is pinned no reason for me to
relieve all of that tension right away
i'm gonna get rid of your knight so my
rook can come back into the game and
we'll deal with the rest later now the
reason why i'm not such a big fan of
this move is it is uh allowing stuff
like wait never mind i'm just i'm the
worst ever i forgot queens move sideways
hardest rule in chess queens moving
sideways
uh even i miss it all the time so
i take it all back g5 gets my stamp of
approval seems to be winning a night and
the game which is very very good not
quite as pretty as bishop takes g3 but
maybe even a bit better
maybe even better than bishop takes g3
okay knight f3 instead but this knight
is capturable and takes loses now to
checkmates
if you really want to keep things simple
you can take on e2 now just
cut it cut out all the complications i
have an extra rook you have one bishop
left on the board i'm going to be able
to win
that's probably the approach i would
take at this point no reason to be fancy
and try to checkmate the opponent
okay yeah g4 but again this feels a
little bit too fancy this is
you can take this
you can just take this and then you get
the same position except you have fewer
g pawns
okay pendulum understands his mistake
just get rid of these pieces
you know i'm good enough a chest to win
with an extra rook
and that is what we're dealing with now
yeah uh i'm gonna be honest with you
though with two minutes on the clock the
position was a lot easier with an extra
g pawn now um you know white has one two
three pawns for a rook
obviously that's not enough
but three pawns or three pawns and in
time pressure anything could happen
maybe you blunder a bishop somewhere and
suddenly your opponent has an exchange
in three pawns
uh rather than uh
just three pawns for the rook
that being said though uh by all
accounts kendrick winning this game most
likely result yeah we see bishop takes
h2 the first pawn falls rook g8 and the
second pawn will fall
pawn number two
just bishop d6 instead
also perfectly fine
okay rook h3 eyeing out bishop f4
with some of these ideas
okay king to e4
yeah and so pendulum here actually isn't
making the most progress um
in fact i would argue that white is
getting pretty close to some scary stuff
if we take this guy take back b5 b6
looks a little frightening but the the
good news for pendulum is he's
maintaining his clock advantage so i
can't be too upset with him
there's also this move rook g3 coming
which i i think should have been done a
long time ago we just we need to get rid
of this g pawn so we can focus all of
our attention on the other side of the
board so rook g3 i think is a must here
uh just to get rid of this last pawn and
then you can focus on the other side of
the board you have your own past pawn on
f3 and that's going to allow you to uh
to win the game
uh without too many worries
okay bishop e5 not a huge fan of this
move not a huge fan of this move every
tempo we waste is another another step
forward for these pawns
yeah so
black now is is just fully committing to
trying to stop these pawns but
i feel it's slipping i feel it slipping
away here i'm i'm getting nervous okay
please we need the king we need the king
the king to help out here okay king e6
this is good
okay c7
uh you can play king d7 now
you can sacrifice potentially but i'm
not even convinced you're winning if
you're going to give up the the bishop
now
probably check he does sacrifice
i'm not convinced that this is a winning
position anymore i'm really not there's
bishop b6 there's bishop f4
yeah this one is is just a draw now
amazingly
what play from sweetman oh my god he
sacrifices the rook
no it is just a draw
oh pendulum uh he's going to want this
one back he's going to want this one
back
um i thought at least kendra would try
to to win on time
um with the the rook versus the bishop
uh just by sort of shuffling around but
instead we get a draw wow
what what play from from sweet man so
how did this happen how did this happen
let me go back through some stuff here
and try to explain so
we got from this position where after
takes takes what black is just
completely crushing
uh we got from here black lost that g
pawn won this h pawn
and then after this move uh starting
from bishop d6 i think black played a
lot of bad moves in a row and the result
of that is that all of the white pawns
slowly crept up the board and the
further down those pawns get the more
dangerous they are you know when they're
sitting on b2 and c3 not so dangerous
when they're on b6 and c7 a pretty
dangerous pawns so here black needed to
play urgently take off this g pawn
focus on pushing this f pawn down the
board and then there's no way white can
can deal with with the numerous threats
instead we saw a wasted move a wasted
move a wasted move
a trade a wasted move number four
bishop e5 wasted move number five
rook h1 wasted move number six
and then six wasted moves was enough was
enough
and we ended up with a draw crazy stuff
crazy crazy stuff that sweet man was
able to save that game
okay with that let me take a gander at
our current standings so as expected uh
actually with that draw enterprises lead
over edward jones it's just slightly
bigger bc enterprise is up if i can do
some math 25 and a half points over
edward jones now they are paired in our
second round of tonight and if you win
the match you actually get a 20 point
bonus towards the grand prix so if
edward jones beats enterprise by six or
more points they will be our number one
seed heading into the final four if
they're unable to do that enterprise is
going to be our number one seed that's
definitely what we want to focus on and
we do have games starting to get
underway here let's take a look we see
vishal bhardwaj the warrior for edward
jones uh who has
secured them uh numerous victories in
the corporate chess league up against
kamikaze knight the unstoppable force of
the corporate chess league fall season
he just wins every game
so let's see what happens here what can
vishal do
against kamikaze knights
okay we get e5
i expect knight to d5 is is the idea
here
uh interesting opening opening from from
kamikaze knight okay knight e4 also a
good idea um this knight of course is
pinned so we are not losing a piece in
the opening
uh and what we're going to see here is
that the shawl gets a big center early
on and black is again going to try to
undermine it with various pawn breaks
playing c5 playing f6 and the like
so knight e4 just bishop d2 to break the
pin
but i actually
don't really like this now for white the
bishop's pair is the bishop's pair as
they say the two bishops working very
well together to control huge swaths of
the board and it is a nice little uh
advantage to be able to take
a bishop or with your knight
you know i and as soon as i finish
saying that we see kamikaze knight
playing bishop takes f3 unprovoked i
really don't like this move i
really don't like this move this
this bishop was um
what was like a master a masterpiece
over here look at this bishop on the
long diagonal putting all that pressure
and then you give all of that up just to
double some pawns
not such a big fan
not such a big fan here
for vishal
okay let's see if i can pull up some of
the other games of course fishers with
men is underway against moneyballin we
have justini linguini against kendalum
and i don't believe alex's game against
21 gigawatts has started just yet i'm
sure they are working on getting
underway
so to my point you see now white's
bishop appearing on e4 controlling a
large portion of the board uh a portion
of the board it would not be able to
control if a bishop on b7 were still
there
f5 though is a nice move by kamikaze
knight trying to undermine this bishop
you would love to play takes on passant
but that's going to activate the the
black queen as well force you to do
something like queen side castles defend
the d-pawn but it's going to be an
interesting game
okay instead we see bishop takes knight
again
and again i don't like this move i just
don't i don't like this move bishops are
good knights are bad keep your bishops
don't give them up for free
um
we do see queen side castles anyways
but now
god what is going on here there's some
c5 idea maybe just castles is prudent
we see a3 challenging this bishop and
again bishop takes knight gets played
just because
uh the players hate me
um i guess
i'm just kidding of course uh and we'll
we'll leave this game for a little bit
now i think uh kamikaze knight
seems to have solidified things and at
the end of the day uh he's gonna be able
to bring a rook to d8 put some pressure
on this d4 pawn and white is under just
just a little bit of pressure here
although i don't think it's it's
anything too bad
um let's move on to board two which is
fissures of men
with the black pieces against
moneyballin
and what's going on here um as the music
is officially underway above me i don't
know how much of that you can hear but
we've got we've got some background
music for uh for the corporate chess
league
um
okay we've got white with the bishop
pair as i was saying bishops are great
knights are the worst uh but what does
black have in exchange for it well in
exchange for it white's king side
structure has been a little bit
fractured and you see the the black
piece is looming just in the area here
looking for an opportunity to jump in
and and give that white king some
trouble
that's why we see white for the moment
not doing anything crazy like f4 which
might allow a knight to jump in g4 just
keeping his pawns here controlling both
of these black knights
instead he's diverting the attention to
the d file if he can simplify things a
little bit the bishop pair will reign
supreme as they wrote about in the
chessbooks
so rook d7 but you know these trades are
not bad for for white at all the end
game is one area where the bishops will
truly dominate these knights just
controlling
huge parts of a wide open chessboard the
knights are not going to be able to keep
up
okay knight takes on d7 play rook d1
again just get the rook to the open file
there are other options queen e4 for
example and you can get away with this
f4 move if you really want to i would
rather do it after something like queen
e4 though
queen e4 does that run into something
crazy like f5 i
don't think so i think f5 is a little
bit too crazy again always weakens the
slight square diagonal rook d1 is the
simple choice and it's not a bad choice
at all
moneyballin still keeping things under
control here
and yeah not much else to say good
position for white we'll see if
moneyballin can continue to manage the
weakness around his king and
uh keep these bishops in good position
uh let's take a look then at board three
we've got justini
linguini up against pendulum
and is this true did they already play a
game
there's no way that's true that that
must be a warm-up game they played uh
there's no way that that kendalum has
already won a game against uh justine
linguini i refuse to believe it
uh so what do we have here we have a big
big center for whites we have a bishop
threatening to be trapped over here on
the king's side for black
but black again
castled the king played responsibly and
having this extra pawn here on the
king's side is going to give the black
king a lot more safety than you might
otherwise expect
and that's why after rookie 8 i have to
say that i think i like black's position
here it on the surface level these pawns
look scary for black but black's done
everything right castled the king
developed the pieces and now he's
reaping the rewards pressure on white's
center and white having to stall the
attack because this king is still stuck
on e1
now i'm looking at things like f5
already black is able to do things like
f5 only because he castled the king so
early on
okay h6 i think that is a missed
opportunity i think f5 was
uh sort of devastating there for for
white no way to keep the e4 pawn under
control and once the e4 pawn goes then
your king is in massive massive trouble
uh h6 instead though anticipates the h5
threat gives the bishop a flight square
not a bad move by any means
okay g5 so this move increases the
tension to the maximum but unfortunately
it's uh provoking the move f5 which i
still think is very very strong
very very strong okay f5 there's e5
maybe this is
is the idea
but against e5 i'm you know i'm thinking
i can just take that guy
that's what i'm thinking i'm thinking i
can take that guy rip open the file and
punish you for leaving your king in the
center of the board
by the way if you don't like that line
maybe you'll like bishop takes knight
takes and then f5 just a bit better when
the knight is
truly pinned
okay the players don't like any of my
lines and they take on g5 and play h5
yeah again i think there were just
tactics available for black there and
the the reason there are tactics
available white left the king in the
center black didn't therefore black has
all the tactics
with this though this is going to give
white some opportunity to
rectify his mistakes play something like
queen c2 castle queen's side
and continue the game
that being said definitely i prefer
black here just because he's so far
ahead in king's safety
right let's take a look then at board
number four which is going to be this
game between alex kurford for edward
jones
and 21 gigawatts playing for enterprise
and it is an interesting game on board
for we do still have some tension in the
center but white has this very nice
looking fluid structure going on the
question is can he
hold everything together the e4 pawn
does seem to be a little bit of a weak
point here
and black is threatening to simply take
take and take
so what can alex come up with maybe just
queen f3 defends the pawn it's simple
enough if you want to get a little bit
more tactical you might have rook d1
here anticipating takes and takes when
the rook would be
opposing the enemy queen don't think i'm
a big fan of it though because of these
checks that occur
on the
on this diagonal again whenever you move
this pawn weakens your king checks and
tactics are going to be in the air
so queen f3 it is queen f3 simple enough
you take some time off from your big
attack that you're trying to set up just
to defend your center and enjoy the
benefits of that
okay alex does go for it for rook d1
uh but now takes takes check and what do
you do what do you do or check first
i think you have to play like queen f2
here
excuse me sorry
something like queen f2
and then uh the e4 pawn is gonna fall
king h1 now uh you know
now it's getting worse now after takes i
don't think you can take back otherwise
knight takes a knight f2 so
getting dangerous for alex here getting
very very dangerous if black were to
take on e4 which of course you should
uh you cannot take that pawn back you
have to push past with something like
d4 otherwise it is big trouble big
trouble for
for white here
we do see takes and will alex fall into
the trap
will he fall into the trap
or is there knight c4
maybe knight c4 is the idea
yeah things are going to get a little
bit crazy here again you know we sort of
had a calmer position while the pawns
were in tension but then the second that
something gets captured you see all the
tactics start to fly
and
all the action going on these knight f2
threats these knight c4 threats
everything is suddenly in the air once
things open up
so now i do think we have to go back
with queen c7 and just allow white to
capture on a5 otherwise you know knight
d6 is an idea
um we can try knight h5 but white's just
gonna move the queen and we've only made
our problems worse so
queen c7 it is queen d8 might
technically be the same
or similar
okay wait actually queen c7 is still
knight d6 i i forgot about this bishop
over here
so queen c7 knight d6 and and what's
going on then
yeah i'm honestly not even sure it's
it's that good for white you know we're
still getting stuff like uh like take on
d3 you can take my rook i'll take back
and knight e4 is is still coming into
the position and still looks rather
frightening
so a lot going on in this game i kind of
want to stick with this one for a while
and see what happens when when the dust
settles
what will happen when the dust settles
queen b3
is the nice idea for black responding to
the attack on black's bishop with an
attack on white's bishop
now if knight d6 the bishop falls and 21
gigawatts trying to solve all the
problems at once here
let's see if he gets away with it
it feels a little artificial to put this
queen on b3 i can start kicking this
piece around
take on d3 take take and i can take this
bishop
right maybe rook b1 the idea is to go
just queen to a4 though
i don't know something feels fishy
something feels fishy here for uh for
black
but maybe it's all working
maybe it is just working
okay worst case with the white pieces i
can defend my bishop
or move it out of the thread of capture
something like bishop to c5 then black
is going to be posed with two problems a
threat to the bishop and the threat to
the rooks and
can only solve both by playing bishop to
c7
and then again it's
white on the move
and what can we do actually queen b3
maybe this is such such a good move
because uh
i'm not sure how alex is solving his
problems he was really relying on these
tactical ideas to bail him out of
hanging his e4 upon but
if the tactics aren't working then then
what else is there
what else is there for white
see what alex can come up with
knight d2 hangs a bishop knight a5 queen
a3 just looks no good just looks no good
okay knight a5 just queen e3 though
queen a3 rather queen a3
the knight can come back to c4 but the
black queen will jump into c5
and applause applause for 21 gigawatts
more applause for 21 gigawatts
the crowd goes wild
for these tactics okay knight back to c4
i thought was the idea but again queen
c5 very very strong idea
uh so looking good now for 21 oh
okay knight knight to b7 yeah that one
is
not not what you want to do knights
don't belong to knight don't fee and
cuddle your knights everybody think out
of knights not so good they uh are very
much hampered by the end of the board
you know i can't go to
can't go to i don't know z six the
letter before a i can't go to z eight i
can't go to a nine i can't go to c nine
i'm stuck with only four legal moves and
three of those moves are going to hang a
knight here so yeah rook c7
knights just gotta come back and it just
feels like you're losing some time
with the white pieces okay looking good
for 21 gigabytes he's in control here uh
in the meanwhile what's going on in the
rest of our match we have money ballin
and fischer's men
drawing their game by agreement some
sort of perpetual here so moneyballin
not actually able to handle that
weakness around the white king that's
the critical point i kept bringing up
this position great for white with the
bishops but just a little bit of
weakness around here and black was able
to
able to use that again by the way bishop
takes knight uh horrible horrible move
just don't give up your bishop
for for a night like this guys stop stop
doing this your bishops are so strong
and just trade it for free for a night
is probably what gave away a lot of the
the advantage here
and then yeah
uh just a simple perpetual to draw that
game uh so fishers of men surviving that
one despite uh
definitely having a worse position okay
with that let's check back in
on board one here we've got kamikaze
knight and vishal still duking it out it
looks like they actually drew their
first game
is that true i think that is true and it
seems like it's true
okay bishop c5 is winning a queen what
what's
oh that's nasty white was rolling down
the board with these pawns just
completely killing it
in fact has an extra exchange in the
position
f6 and then sacrificed the bishop in
stunning fashion only to hang a queen
only to hang a queen we joined at the
right moment that being said white's
position was so good to start with then
he might still win this game
uh in fact he might just be objectively
better here
despite having a rook and a bishop for
the queen
yeah in fact how does black stop
checkmate
very scary stuff okay d4 this is
probably a good try for black
um because you need to bring this queen
out this way so your king can escape
but now okay rook g3 isn't played i
really expected rook g3 to come on the
board now
uh but yeah now i think something like
maybe even queen a2 introducing ideas of
checks and clearing an escape route for
the king that's what you need to survive
here you need to get this king out of
the king site where all of these white
pieces are just swarming
this does allow f7 but now okay so king
h7
and now simply queens i guess is is the
idea
and yeah
the idea of trying to escape was nice
but this f7 move
puts a stop to it
and queens should be good enough here
good enough
if it's not check meeting immediately
it's at least winning a full rook
and then
white will will have a very nice end
game
so let's calculate queens rook takes
okay bishop d2 is check
not so sure this was necessary though
not so sure this was necessary
yeah now you still queen and i think you
kind of have to now
otherwise you you run some serious risks
is he considering rook f4 the idea of
like checkmate or something i don't know
i don't believe it just just queen the
pawn just queen the pawn don't be greedy
ah okay rook f6
and
once again the players are proving that
they are very good at chess um king g7
bishop h6 king h7
uh bishop f8 is is checkmate so
wow
kamikaze knight proving me wrong finding
a forced checkmate not just queening the
pawn finding better impressive stuff
impressive stuff
and so kamikaze knight takes out vishal
on board one
giving uh enterprise a lead
and with that you know i don't want to
call
it already
but it's looking very very tough for
edward jones to score enough points and
to uh to take that first place position
away from enterprise they might already
have secured it
that being said kamikaze knight needs to
see mate in two here can he find maton
two it's a pretty one it's a pretty one
it's a little bit unusual so
understandable if he misses it
um that being said though
richie iii not quite enough because i
have king f8 you're still obviously
winning with bishop h6 and queens but uh
bishop h6 is is a bit better
okay we have this
first
check is the idea i guess it's not quite
checkmate anymore uh not by force at
least
but obviously still quite good okay now
this one is checkmate okay there you go
he found mate in three rather than the
matin 2 but this one
far less beautiful and i will never
forgive him for it
um that's okay though he gets the point
for uh for enterprise
let's check back in on justine linguini
verse is pendulum it's coming down to
the wire here both players and time
pressure
white obviously with a winning position
but only 36 seconds
to to figure it out
only 36 seconds that being said
tough to play any legal moves here with
black okay we're going to see the knight
or the bishop get sacrificed for these
two pawns
and once again one side has an extra
rook uh i've you know last time it was
kendall with the extra rook and he
actually wasn't able to win we'll see if
justine justini linguini can succeed
where kendralum could not and 96 that's
a good move that's actually checkmate
and one now justini gets it done
uh okay moving on that is good news for
edward jones that is going to level the
match with enterprise
um and then what's going on in alex's
game it's again coming down to the wire
it looks tough for alex just a moment
ago but it looks like things have
improved drastically we left it at
knight a5 knight d5 was the choice but
this just gives up your extra pawn no
need to do that simply take on d3 push
through to e3 all of those moves were
good but yeah now okay you know i take
it all back uh what what black did was
also pretty good
um but then
uh hangs a queen and a rook uh back rank
threats back rank threats guys that's
that's what you got to look out for and
alex gets it done with the back rank
idea
should go on to win this game
yeah black is quickly running out of
pieces
um there's some still matrix i guess
but nothing too crazy i think king h2 is
amazingly the fastest path to checkmate
just because you want to play um
well queen g4 if h6 and if king here
yeah just just king h2 and queen g4 is
mate
just have to waste a single tempo okay
g4 and queen f6
queen e7 queen h6 all checkmate and one
queen h6 for alex and that'll end the
game
okay with that uh edward jones is off to
a lead in the match then
and yes somehow uh justine linguini
against kendalum we saw the first time i
clicked on that game
we saw that it showed a point for
kendalum already i didn't want to
believe it i didn't think it was true
but could it be that kendram won their
first game in like a minute and a half
and i just didn't see any of it because
it's marked it's marked on the pairing
sheet that they you know they've played
both games maybe it's true
if that is true it's all going to come
down to the second game between fishers
of men and moneyballin in the second
game between alex and 21 gigawatts we
have enterprise with a one point lead at
the moment edward jones would have to
win on both of these boards to win the
match
and what's going on here looks like a
rook in game and what is this decision
my god money ballin he could take the
rook have a fine end game instead he
takes the pawn on b4 uh going down the
exchange for a pawn
um not no not good not good rook c1 rook
d7 your pawns are toast buddy your pawns
are toast
keep it simple keep it simple you know
bishop for a rook that's good take it
don't don't try to over press like that
yeah king b8 rook d7 and your pawns are
just going to fall one by one
very tough stuff
yes you did lose the game oh no
uh sorry to hear that sorry to hear that
the good news is you got it done in
round two and uh
your team definitely has good chances to
still win this match against enterprise
especially with fishers of men now is
taking a significant advantage in his
second game against moneyballing okay
rook c8 but this is no good we we get
the f7 pawn um then it's just a clean
exchange for whites
you can defend your g7 pawn like this
but king d3 my king is entering the
position rook e7 immediately also picks
up another pawn it's impossible to
defend both of these e5 runs into rook
g7
and yeah rookie 7 is fisher's men's
choice
uh okay
so with this white picks up another pawn
uh black is hoping on the b pawn to be
the saving grace here wants to push this
pawn get it far down the board and give
white some trouble but i don't think
it's going to be good enough here uh
we've got rook takes e6 coming
um
yeah rook b6 is fine rookie four is fine
just just any move is fine and i do
expect fishers of men to convert this
position
which brings us to alex kurford versus
21 gigawatts with action early on in the
opening already what is this
what happened here we had a french
knight c3 c5 okay
knight f6 e5 knight back to g8 yeah this
is stuff that's that's beyond my uh
beyond my understanding i'm no no french
sicilian line uh player
so yeah knight f6 e5 knight g is this a
real thing this doesn't feel like a real
thing uh but let's see what what
happened anyways we had a lot of back
and forth in the opening
eventually black does break with d5
which feels very very important you just
can't exist in this position with your
pawn stuck here on d7
so d5 liberates things a little bit and
we saw queen c7
which actually might allow knight b5
but this wasn't played instead b4
and knight takes b4 taking advantage of
the loose piece here on c4
uh bishop b3 was played uh black
retreats with the knight and we just
just get a trade again
knight b5 probably a bit better you want
to get rid of that that bishop it's a
good piece it's a good piece it seems to
be the theme of tonight bishops for
knights that's that's what you want to
do and the players all seem to disagree
with me at every turn
now knight f4 and we see the power of
this bishop supporting the other pieces
as they advance
and yeah couldn't have said it better
myself uh to the music that's that's how
i feel um with the white pieces here
just
uh you know
you know you know what i mean
uh what's going on in the other matches
by the way we have a
uh perfect score for worldwide
technology against dardy they won six
out of six
and for ascension versus bayer
what is going on there it looks like
another close match ascension is up by
one heading into
the last few games but they are
definitely capable
of a comeback in that match
okay now alex does have the extra pawn
uh it's this pawn here on e6 that's on a
post and some pretty active pieces you
see b6 just gonna bring this bishop out
to b7
and highlight the fact that this knight
and bishop are working well together
because of that pressure we see 21
gigawatts commit to this move g3
now this move does get rid of the knight
but it's only going to increase the
power of this bishop once it lands on b7
knight d3 is bold by alex putting the
knight on a square where it's not
defended but it's only temporary this
knight's headed back to c5 will be on a
very very strong outpost
in knight c5 it is
now bishop b7 and this position is is
going from bad to worse for for 21
gigawatts here looks very very tough
checking back in on this end game uh
fishers of men did end up converting it
um just don't stalemate the black king
and you will win this game
so let's stick with alex then this is
the key match here
the key match alex versus 21 gigawatts
we get bishop to b4 yeah and bishop b7
is easy mode for alex you just pin this
knight to the king becomes very very
difficult to keep this piece defended
queen c6 as well it's going to be coming
on the board and it's
looking very very tough looking very
tough
we might see some simplifications here
um but the the sad truth of it is you
know even when pieces come off the board
this pin is going to be nearly
impossible to to break for example i'm
looking at
king g2 knight p3 queen b3
uh queen c6
or i'm sorry
bishop b4 ab4 queen c6
and you just you can't break this pin
you can't break this pin
um that being said i think that's all a
little bit unnecessary oh yeah and queen
c6 first was my idea i'm sorry queen c6
putting on this pressure forces queen c3
or something awkward oh and then
actually just bishop e5 oh bishop e5 at
the end there queen takes queen f3 queen
g2 is mate
yeah things are things are bad things
are real bad
things are real real bad
check out this tactic oh my god so if
you go
queen c3 i go bishop e5 queen e3 is the
only way to defend both pieces and then
i just go bishop d4
and after bishop d4 queen e2 is the only
move you have or queen f4 to defend the
knight and either one of those moves is
going to drop your bishop on b3 just
inching up the board
fearless invincible bishop and you
you're gonna win the game you can also
throw in bishop takes rick by the way so
those are the tactics for alex here
let's see if he can find any of them
see if he can find him
he's got the time for it seven minutes
on the clock
seven minutes on the clock
[Music]
in the meantime fischer's event does
find checkmate with the extra queen
against moneyballin that brings us to a
tied match
with just this game remaining
just the one game left to go
wait a second i'm just doing the math
wrong i'm just totally doing the math
wrong
21 gigawatts needs to win this match or
needs to win this game to tie the match
alex only needs a draw here not not a
full win to win okay that makes sense
that makes sense okay queen c3 and alex
still waiting i want to see bishop e5 on
the board ooh knight e4 instead okay
this move probably also wins so i can't
be too mad knight e4 is pretty good the
queen will move and alex's idea is to
just play something like knight d2 or
knight g5 add yet another attacker to
this piece
and uh you know
ask white what he's doing to solve the
problems that being said
you know after knight or queen e39 g5
for example there's bishop d1
i don't see the checkmate just yet
but i mean obviously not going to be an
ideal position for uh
for white to say the least
um by the way g5 g4 not a ridiculous
idea here not a ridiculous idea
just brute force add another attacker
that night and uh call it quits
okay queen d3 is played instead
bishop b4 rook d8
looks pretty reasonable rick d
immediately also very reasonable
it's knight g5 idea i'm honestly not so
fond of because after bishop d1
maybe maybe white's holding on somehow
that being said if you calculate a
little bit
um knight g5 bishop d1 bishop takes
bishop pawn takes rook d8 queen moves
out of the way rook takes d1 probably
you're just check mating there but rook
d8 also a very good move not gonna spoil
anything
definitely not going to spoil anything
there
in the meantime we have some more
results we have ascension now up by two
games against bayer bayer's gonna have
to win out to tie that match we can
check in on those games as well
we've got vindy versus s gilmore here
vindy with the extra piece looks like he
might be able to score a point for bayer
and that leaves us with crossta pj
against maurice gp
uh so across the pj playing for bayer
with the white pieces here hoping to win
this drawn
rook end game if he is able to do so
uh he will give his team good chances to
tie the match against bayer
unfortunately for him though just a draw
is not going to be enough here with a
draw ascension is going to secure
victory against bayer in this match so
down four minutes on the clock not
looking totally promising but maybe he
finds some some tricks
okay after b6 if i'm maurice gp and i
know the match situation i'm capturing
that guy i'm entering rook versus rook
and i'm agreeing to a draw so looks like
ascension is going to be able to get it
done barring you know somebody winning
in rook versus rook meanwhile how did
the tactics go uh bishop takes on b4 we
saw queen takes knights
an interesting idea but it's not good
enough rook d3 in the ends and
alex is picking up this knight on f3 as
i said it's just nearly impossible to to
escape from that pin on the light
squares when there's no pawns left to
help defend
so alex now can take the knight at his
leisure takes with the rook i probably
would have taken with the bishop on rook
d8 rook d1 traded off the rest of the
pieces with the checkmating threats and
then just one with a bishop versus a
versus nothing
instead the rook takes allows king g1
and i mean
still an extra piece still an extra
piece can't be too mad
can't be too mad here
rook over to c3 is going to pick up the
c pawn
um rick c7 would defend but again
black's just going to be bringing in the
rest of the pieces okay rookie one this
does just drop the c pawn now rook takes
c4 seems fine
if you're alex the last thing you want
to do is hang backrank checkmate
somewhere so at some point it's probably
a good idea to play h6 something like g5
or g6
any of those moves is going to be good
enough
okay bishop f3 instead
um so alex may be realizing his mistake
realizes the bishop is going to be
strong on f3 and yeah ricky three but
this unfortunately hangs checkmate and
alex the hero for edward jones goes 2-0
on board four to secure match victory
against enterprise however
unless i did the math wrong i think
enterprise scored just enough points to
save their top seed position uh going
into the final four it's not going to
matter a great deal but definite
bragging rights heading into the finals
for enterprise along with that slight
edge in tie breaks that i mentioned
where they would get to select their
color in the event of an armageddon
playoff
and that leaves us with just one game
remaining and oh my god
we had a result in rook versus rook
oh no
okay well first of all black missed the
win earlier
but
yeah we see we see the rook actually
falling i did i didn't expect this to
happen i did i really didn't but yeah
rook versus rook
not not so good not not so good
yeah this is like the the one tactic
that you can hang in rick versus rook
and unfortunately
it was hung it was hung and checkmate
was delivered unfortunately for across
the pj you know the result might have
been decisive but it was decisive in the
wrong in the wrong direction so
with that
um ascension secures match victory and
then vindy actually just runs out of
time runs out of time had the extra
piece blundered the extra piece and then
ran out of time so the worst has
happened for bayer in these last two
games and ascension
goes home with match victory uh in in
this game as well
so what has that done let us recap what
has happened tonight in round one we saw
enterprise taking out their second place
competitors worldwide technology that
allowed edward jones to leapfrog
worldwide technology with a win over
ascension and bayer does defeat doherty
on the third match
then in round two we see edward jones
just barely beating enterprise by a
couple points thanks to alex carford on
board four
maybe this is foreshadowing things to
come in the final four next week maybe
this is foreshadowing edward jones and
enterprise definitely the top two seeds
going in
uh meanwhile worldwide technology proves
that they belong in the final four as
well sweeping doherty with six wins out
of six uh and ascension does defeat
bayer uh in the third match as well also
showing that they belong in this final
four next week as well
so lots to look forward to next week we
will be doing the final four in person
at the st louis chess club so i look
forward to getting all these players
back here in the chess club to battle it
out to win the fall season of the
corporate chess league
let's take one last look at the grand
prix standings here
i believe these are accurate we end with
enterprise at 246
points and edward jones ending just two
and a half points behind at 243.5
worldwide technology ends on 226 points
also very respectable and ascension also
qualifying for the final four with 147
and bayern dardy both ending their
seasons with 85 points and 38.5 points
respectively
and thank you to all of the teams uh who
played in the corporate chess league
here uh in the fall season we've loved
having all of you i know it's been a
little bit weird with a hybrid event and
online events and i'm glad we can end it
uh in person back at the chess club big
thank you especially to bayern dardy
whose seasons are ending tonight we hope
to see you both back in the spring
season of 2022.
uh with that once again mark your
calendars same time next week next
thursday corporate chess
we will finally see who will reign
supreme over the corporate chess league
thank you all so much for watching as
always my name is caleb denvey and i
will see you next thursday
you